and i hope you don't take this the wrong
way but when i was considering the the
list of names that the government might
put up for interview this morning yours
was not necessarily at the top of the
list and you will understand why it
wasn't that long ago that you were being
pretty openly critical about boris
johnson and perhaps his longevity i'm
just wondering does your appearance this
morning mean that you're back to being
bffs
no look it's very clear i obviously have
had some differences with the government
over the last couple of years about how
it's handled the kovid pandemic i would
have preferred we'd got the economy
firing on all cylinders a little bit
earlier than the government um and
obviously before christmas
i led a bit of a rebellion um about the
restrictions the government put in place
but actually i think that was the right
thing to do i think it meant the
government held its nerve
over christmas
and we've seen that the figures have
remained the same we've got the economy
firing on all cylinders and thank
goodness we did because it was only a
few hours between getting all of those
restrictions lifted
and then we saw the appalling russian
invasion of ukraine and we've gone from
one crisis straight into another which
provides obviously a very difficult and
challenging backdrop for the chancellor
as he sets out his spring statement
later today yeah it certainly does but
at the same time you also did say
regarding the kind of the ongoing role
about partygate and who you what and
when in an arrival dining street you did
say that you wanted to wait for the
conclusion of the metropolitan police's
inquiry we are not at that point so
again i will say it does rather feel
that what is happening in ukraine has
perhaps to some extent shaped your view
of the prime minister
no i've been very clear on on the the
issues around
how downey street dealt with uh the
so-called party gates are i've said i'm
prepared to wait the prime minister
wants us to judge him on the facts i've
said i'll wait for the conclusion of the
metropolitan police criminal
investigation which is ongoing and the
full su grey report when she completes
that and that's published but that's a
judgment i think for another day we've
obviously got this important uh ukraine
situation uh ongoing and the
government's obviously doing a good job
on leading uh opinion on that and then
we've got the very important spring
statement today so partygate hasn't gone
away but it's not first day it's for a
day in the future when the mets finished
its inquiry and the sugray report is
published indeed well let's get straight
on to the economics of it all and as
you're just hearing we have had those
latest inflation figures cpi up from 5.5
to 6.2 percent certainly feels like we
may well be on track for 8 as predicted
in april do you think it's an
inevitability that we're going to hit
double figures at some point this year
well look i think what is certain is
that actually the economic picture is
very uncertain because of what's
happening uh in europe uh uh with the
ukrainian situation uh and i think
anyone who thinks now they can forecast
what's going on in the autumn i think is
likely to be wrong i think what it does
illustrate
is the chancellor's got competing
pressures today he understands the
situation facing uh consumers and
businesses but he also needs to make
sure that that inflation outlook the
fact that interest rate pressures are
going upwards uh death interest is
higher and he also needs to build in
some resilience to deal with whatever
the the future may throw at us so those
challenges i think are all competing um
and provide a difficult balancing act
for today and i think that's the
judgment that i'm confident that he'll
get right when he sets out his statement
at lunchtime
of course we have heard from the chance
of you know facing quite a lot of
pressure over the the pending increase
to national insurance that that it will
go ahead that there is a necessity to it
i mean you would concede i'm sure that
the cabinet is not united on this
particular issue let alone the party i
mean is there perhaps some wiggle room
for rishi sunak and perhaps tinkering
with the threshold in terms of north in
terms of national insurance
well look i can't comment on the
specifics of what's going to be
announced today but i think on the
national insurance rise it's very clear
we've said we're going to put an extra
12 billion pounds into first of all into
the health service to deal with the
backlogs that have arisen because of the
pandemic and then a long-term funding
central settlement for social care if
you're going to say you're against the
national insurance rise taking place
either this year or in the future you've
got to say whether you're prepared to
not put that money into the health
service or social care or come up with
some other way to pay for it people that
say they want to put off these rises
but still want to go ahead with the tax
rises and uh the spending increases are
just not being serious to labour for
example the chancellor doesn't have
money to play around with but still
it's not as if the chancellor doesn't
have money to play around with i mean
estimates vary but we are talking about
tens of billions of extra revenue
sitting in the exchequer at the moment
well i think i think one of the problems
is everyone's looking at the the upside
points and there may well be i haven't
seen the forecast there may well be
extra revenue but i think people are
forgetting there are also extra costs so
there are cost pressures on public
services and also we've actually
obviously had to borrow a very
significant amount of money rightly in
my opinion to deal with the
economic impact of the pandemic but that
means the economy is vulnerable to rises
in interest rates
and inflation and we saw yesterday very
significant debt interest payments the
chancellor has to be mindful of that
when he's making decisions and you know
we were able to help consumers with an
announcement in february of nine billion
pounds to deal with uh a big chunk of
the rise in energy cost that was only
possible because the chancellor had some
resilience built into the system and i
think given the uncertain outlook for
the rest of the year i want to make sure
that there's a certain amount of
resilience built in so that we can deal
with whatever shops are thrown at us in
the future and the government can
respond to help consumers and businesses
cope with what the world throws is them
sure
a very specific question
from your perspective is this a point
where the chancellor could rely on on
extra borrowing or should we be using
these surpluses and there are surpluses
to start paying down some of the debt
well i don't think i think pretending
that you can continue borrowing at the
level that we have been over the the
pandemic i think just isn't serious we
we borrowed for a one-off
shock
which was the biggest economic shock for
300 years that was the right thing to do
to protect millions of jobs and
thousands of businesses that was
successful we've if you look at the
recovery from the pandemic we've got
some of the best numbers uh across the
world we've got a record number of
people on payrolls we've got very low
unemployment you know businesses have
started recovering but we've got to make
sure that we continue that sensible
economic management
and we build some resilience into the
system to deal with whatever the world
throws at us so i think the chancellor
i'm sure will look to help consumers and
businesses where he can uh and is on
people's sides but i think he's also got
to be mindful of very very uncertain
position coming in the future and i
think the public would expect him to
build that resilience and that security
into the public finances so that he can
look at dealing with whatever problems
arise in the future yeah well i mean one
of the one of the things that the world
in your words is throwing at us at the
moment is of course the the the violence
that we are seeing in and around ukraine
is there not a really strong argument
for a significant increase in defense
spending at the moment particularly
given the amount of munitions material
that we are providing to the ukrainians
at the moment
well there is and of course we have had
that very significant increase in
defence spending
in the budget that was the largest
increase announced in defence spending
over the next few years uh for some time
and of course the the government's
integrated review had russia
as the top security threats sure that
that that did rather precede the
violence in ukraine though
yes it did but it recognized russia as a
threat it was a very significant
increase in defence spending and we
remain the second largest spender in
nato what's been very welcome of course
is that what's happened in europe has
meant that those european nations who
haven't been spending the two percent of
gdp which we more than exceed have also
now decided to increase
increase their defense spending and
what's important is that nato as a whole
has the resources and the funds to deal
with the threats we face so i welcome
those increases but we made a very big
commitment to defence spending uh in the
budget just a few months ago
um can we talk about em covet uh briefly
mr harper it's two years now since since
the first lockdown so many of us of
course have been affected individually
personally we will all know people who
have been ill many of us will know
people who have died and did we have a
rather brave 13 year old girl who'd be
on the program just a little bit later
this morning telling us about her her
father who passed away what what lessons
have you taken away from the past two
years
well i think first of all
it's been a very difficult year for many
people and a huge number of people have
had very very difficult personal
circumstances to deal with and i'm very
mindful of that
i'm also very conscious that
you know our
scientists and our health services
responded incredibly well so that we
could develop the vaccines get them
rolled out and we're now in a position
where with vaccines and the antivirals
that we've got we're in a position where
we've been able to enable people to get
back to normal
living with the virus it's going to be
with us forever it's not going away and
we've had to deal with that and i think
the country
individual people and some of our
systems have responded very well there
will be lessons to learn which is why
i'm pleased that the public inquiry has
been set up the chair of that inquiry is
consulting on the the terms of reference
they're very broad they'll look at you
know the government's decision-making
the evidence how it balance things and
wage things up and i look forward to
that inquiry i'll be delighted to give
evidence to it in due course and it'll
set out you know when it reports uh the
lessons to be learned for the future
um we do have to let you go mr harper
before you do and you'll have noted the
the royals currently touring the
caribbean at the moment they've been met
by protests in jamaica plenty of anger
plenty of speculation that jamaica may
well be preparing moves to make itself a
republic i'm wondering given that it is
now the time for the royal family to
apologize for its role in benefiting
from slavery
no look i think the royal family leads
uh or sets out these things
very well when it goes on its tools i
don't think it's wise for the royal
family to get involved in in politics
that's a matter for the government and
decisions about the future of jamaica's
constitutional status are a matter for
the people of jamaica and the government
of that country it's a democratic
country and that's right and proper i
think it's much better if the royal
family stays out of politics
and leaves that to the politicians and
they maintain that constitutional status
where they can unite the country and i
think from her majesty the queen
downwards in her jubilee year i think
the royal family do that fantastically
well
mr harper great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us